i'm delighted to say i am joined by the
director of widow steve mcqueen steve
lovely to see you
congratulations on a fantastic film now
tell me this film is
very female focused it's got some
fantastic lead women
the london film festival is very female
focused
at why this story why now was it a happy
coincidence
well it happened 35 years ago i was 13
years old uh a black child in london and
i saw this tv show but in the plant
called widows and
it grabbed me i mean the women were
being sort of judged on their
appearances
and deemed um capable
similar to how i was being judged at
that time but thinking old child
so that was that and it was just
fascinating the story was just amazing
these four women having to sort of
take the reins off of their husbands who
died and it was just one of those things
which i really
was passionate about to make we're a
year on from the weinstein scandal and
the metoo campaign
we're talking about women so much more
we're giving them a prominent role
in film in a much greater way than we
have done before in some ways
do you think there has been real change
in the industry no
not at all um you know change will only
come when
people have power and that's the only
time when people with things will
actually change
there's awareness which is great but in
order things to actually change
people have to have power you have to
have the foot in the sort of
studios a real kind of idea of how to
change
the course of the direction
you are in many ways an agent of change
as a director
i mean what are your priorities to make
films which are truthful
and entertaining audiences it's very
important that
you can actually detain as well as
enlightenment as far as i'm concerned
and
as an artist and filmmaker i think we
have responsibility more than ever
now to do that are you positive in some
ways that we're having the right
conversations at least are we talking
about the right
things extremely positive this has never
happened
before i mean it's kind of bittersweet
this whole idea of me making this film
called widows
i saw it 35 years ago and still nothing
has changed so
it's kind of crazy it's interesting
isn't it the the lead characters in your
film
are basically turned to crime they are
not women that we would aspire to be
i suppose that's the point isn't it they
are not stereotypical roles
and that's what women need is to be
put in roles whichever roles that they
want well
think of uh if you think of uh catherine
hepburn think of betty davis
you know think of all these amazing
actresses who had these amazing
greta garbo amazing roles in the 30s 40s
and 50s
i mean what happened i mean you know why
can't we do the same now these were huge
huge stars in their time
i don't see any reason why we can't sort
of repeat that part of history again
in cinema a couple of years ago at the
oscars we had the oscars so white
campaign
and how do you feel about diversity in
terms of race in the film industry is
that
changing enough quick enough no
but we're on our way the conversation is
being had and
as long as that conversation we have
possible is it possible
there's but until then
you know we just have to sort of plug
away you know it's how it is i mean you
know
i mean come on it's how it is but we
could change the course of direction
through
having some kind of foot in the door and
some kind of power that's the idea
at london film festival 38 of the
filmmakers here this year
are women 50 of um the filmmakers in
competition
are women i mean those stats are pretty
encouraging aren't they
i mean wow that's pretty amazing i mean
wow that's i didn't know that
um yeah that's encouraging i think
london is obviously leading the way
because that's not happening anywhere
else didn't happen in can
didn't happen in venice but it's
happened in london so you know we could
put ourselves on the back for that for
sure
and in part that is due to the people in
power as you said the the festival
director who has chosen those films
precisely
exactly we have a woman who's ahead of
the london film festival
and uh you know is making those great
decisions so
there you go you have to be in business
of power in order to change things
otherwise they just stay the same
because
for those people there'd be no reason to
change they're comfortable on top